je déambule
en bilan
je suis en bulle en bulle spéculative
une bulle aux parois déformant
com ap
pas après pas
dans un jeu de miroirs spa j'ai parfois
l'impression de flotter dans ma bulle
spéculative
je déambule sous un projecteur myope
je déambule j'entre dans la danse j'aime
danser quand on danse
tout est permis ou presque on peut même
tomber car danser nous renvoie à notre
maladresse originale la maladresse
natale vous vous souvenez tous de votre
période foetale non vous dansiez en
lévitation dans l'eau du ventre vous
dansiez tourner en vous retournant à
tâtons maladroit jusqu'à votre première
chute oui votre naissance plus tard le
premier pas qu'y at-il de plus beau que
le premier pas de l'enfant qui avance
qui tangue qui titube balancer chaloupe
rien
rien n'est plus beau
que le premier pas sur le sol terrestre
nous sommes tous maladroit et cette
maladresse nous relient
nous n'en finissons pas de tituber sur
le fil qui nous relient aux autres tels
des des éléphants funambule poussé par
une insatiable curiosité
éléphant funambule ambühl
nous nous découvrons en découvrant le
monde tout le monde et ce tout le monde
se découvre en découvrant dans un
immense de chant de bulles vous me
suivez
alors disons que nous nous inventons en
nous projetant dans les autres autre
bulle autre regard nous nous observons
nous nous imitons nous nous inspirons
dans prenons un exemple simple
ah oui tous les parents connaissent
cette première interaction cette
première réponse du nouveau né je tire
la langue culture la langue simple non
les mots parfois sont tellement
dérisoire d'ailleurs il ya mille et une
façons de tirer la langue
chacun la sienne
à vous bon revenons à notre
malencontreuse maladresse elle se
manifeste tout particulièrement lors des
grandes premières
lors des rencontres notamment
ouais ça dit quelque chose
sapin oui car une force irrépressible
nous pousse à nous rencontrer à échanger
nos bons procédés
à découvrir le monde à travers d'autres
gestes d'autres mots d'autres regards
d'autres regards le regard le regard de
l'eau il nous construit nous grandit
mais peut aussi nous enfermer nous
réduire nous réduire à l'état de glaçons
je veux parler ici du fameux regard
glacial nous peur nos préjugés nous
transforme en sombres et froids
calculateurs c'est automatique
nous croisons quelqu'un ou quelqu'une
époque nous le calculons c'est très
pratique le froid calcul
on peut classer l'autre pratique peut
classer l'autre entre entre normales et
anormales entre normale et petre ans en
entre eux étrange étrange et nous nous
jugeons les uns les autres
selon nos apparences
trompeuse mais il est difficile de
braver nos a priori nos préjugés
difficile de déconstruire les apparences
il ya le haut de l'iceberg et l'iceberg
c'est gros mais pas pour ne citer qu'un
seul exemple certaines personnes sont
nus sous leurs imperméables way dans les
apparences parlons-en
je suis plus maladroit que les autres
je suis trompé par les miroirs
je prends le sucre pour 10 m je serre
les verts à la renverse
une fois dans la rue lors d'une petite
balade
je me suis trompé de copines
je m'approche je saisi sa main près
alors là si tendrement elle a été
surprise
marco pinotti
une autre fois me suis trompé de voiture
le moteur tournait jouve la portière je
m'approche nation à la place du mort
la conductrice s'est légèrement crispé
sur son volant et puis j'aime à me
dégourdir les jambes en toute
convivialité
vous savez ce qu'on appelle communément
un footing et bien vous savez lors d'un
footing
on crache on croise des passants il l'a
mal pris
les gens sont perplexes pour le moins
désarçonné par cet étrange maladresse
l'étrange maladresse qui se traduit en
langage administratif par un mot un mot
valise
un peu lourde
parfois la valise ce mot-valise je ne
résiste pas à l'envié de vous le
présenter au public
je te présente le mot handicap et le
handicap
parlons-en tout d'abord le handicap on
peut être pour ou contre
vaste débat
le handicap on peut toujours le con
penser tant en ce qui me concerne neuf
la réalité est tenace of collante
impossible d'y échapper je suis
handicapé
j'ai toujours sur moi une prothèse
numérique
regardez
c'est bien la preuve que je suis
handicapé
non
mon handicap comme d'autres espèces
toutes plus originales les unes que les
autres jouent à cache cache
il ne se voit pas au premier regard
dans le brouillard
il fait surgir de l'étrange
du luff du burlesque
c'est comme cela qu'ils se manifestent
évidemment cela prête à confusion et
provoque malentendu maldonne
maladresse la revoici voilà la belle
adresse je suis parfois mal vu
alors que je ne vois pas les gens qui me
voient
je suis parfois mal vu alors alors que
je suis mal qui toutes ces situations
rocambolesques montrent évidemment
conduit à réfléchir
devrais-je revêtir un uniforme pour être
rapidement classique parce qu'on n'en
parle plus
pour moi si oui
lequel j'ai acheté une canne blanche
afin d'être rapidement reconnu mais je
n'en ai pas vraiment besoin pour me
déplacer
sam encombre bon les lunettes de stars
n'en parlons pas c'est ridicule
je verrai encore mois
alors quoi chi chi quoi
trouver